So, you have learned Xan's diamond and
now you want to figure out how to move
with it. Well, I've got you covered,
friends. I have three different options
for what you can do to really style out
Xan's Diamond and make it appealing in a
dance kind of fashion. So, let's dive
in.
Drex here from Drexfactor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I am drilling
down three movement options for how you
can flow with Xan Zimmed. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks go to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video. And
just to put a massive thank you out
there to Pekka Becklonin for having
supported this channel for so very long.
I appreciate you and everything that
you've done these past few years. Xans
Diamond, it's an elliptical cap. It's a
third order motion. It fits into a lot
of different frameworks for tech po. And
if you're like me, then when you first
learned it, you thought, "Okay, this is
a thing that I couldn't possibly move
with." And you know what? You and I were
wrong. There's a lot of different
options to move with Zan's diamond as
there are with many tech po tricks. So,
I'm going to start off a little series
here talking about how you can move with
different forms of poet tech and make
them flow. We're going to start with
three different options that are all
different types of jazz. uh dance moves
that we can put together with Xan's
Diamond and maybe get your tech moving a
little bit. And if you need the inside
scoop on how to do Xan's Diamond, I'm
going to include a link to a tutorial on
that down in the description as well as
up in the cards. All right, so we're
going to start things off with just a
simple step touch. So a step touch, for
those of you who don't know, is just a
basic jazz move where you step a foot,
you touch, you step a foot, you touch.
Works like this. There's a lot of
different variations on it. You can
touch behind. You can touch in front.
You don't even have to cross your legs
for it. Sometimes you can step, touch,
step, touch. It's just a very, very
basic way of getting around. You can
think of this as being that you're just
going to tap one foot as you step with
the other. You don't commit your entire
weight to the foot that is doing the
tapping. Any which way you look at it,
you can just drill. I'm going to step,
touch, step, touch, step, touch on the
inside. Boom. on the inside. Boom. On
the outside, boom. On the outside, boom,
or behind or behind or in front or in
front like so. And the great thing about
Xan's Diamond is that since it contains
movements where you're taking it back
and forth like so, it's a perfect fit
for doing a step touch. Again, you can
take it back,
you can take it across,
you can take it forward,
and you can even do the step touch on
the inside like so. Basically, what
you're looking to do is every time you
do that middle part of Xan's diamond
where you're taking it across, that is
your opportunity to do the step. And
when you open up, that's your
opportunity to do the touch. So think
step touch, step touch, step touch, step
touch, like so. All right. So our next
option is something called a jazz slide.
The footwork for this is not so terribly
different from the step touch, except
that instead of stepping and touching,
stepping and touching, you instead take
a big step and then slide your foot
behind you. You want to take an extra
big step almost like you're taking a
jump. And you're going to let the other
foot drag behind you to the side. Here
you see people doing really elaborate
gestures with this when they do it on
stage, especially in like Broadway
choreography. Here's how you make it
work with Xan's diamond, though. Me
personally, I think that this works best
when you're coming from a given side.
So, we have the bit in the center where
we have the PO going back and forth like
this. And when we reach a given side, we
expand out, right? I think that's the
perfect place to do a jazz slide off to
the direction that the po are going to
go. This gets a little tricky then
because it means you basically have to
do a Xan's diamond on each side of the
jazz slide like so. If I go ahead and
start by opening up, I then have to
bring my uh my poi up and down then back
to the side I just came from over here
up down back across. And then when they
come here, that's the time for the next
jazz slide. So I have to do a full
repetition of Xan's diamond every time I
do one of these jazz slides here. Like
so. I don't think that's the end of the
world,
but I do think it looks pretty darn
cool. Don't you? All right. And option
number three, it is that most famous of
all dance moves. Namely, we are going to
play around with pureetses. Where do you
do a pureette in Xan's Diamond? I'm so
glad you asked. You see that horizontal
part? We're going from side to side.
That was so important when we did our
step touches.
Well, that's the place where we're going
to insert one of these uh piouettes. And
in fact, you can really just think of it
as being a piouette that you're doing
with the po and split time opposites
like so. Uh you can do the pyouette
either in the direction of the leg
you're going up on or you can do it as a
jazz pyouette where you are going
against the direction of the foot that
you're standing on. Uh if you don't know
the difference between these, I did a
video on pureetses that I'll go ahead
and link to down in the description as
well as up in the cards. But suffice it
to say, this is a choose your own
adventure with which of the piouettes
you want to do. But basically, you're
looking for those spots where you're
going around to the side, and you want
to go with the direction of the PO as
you go around. So, if I'm carrying the
PO from my left to my right, I'm going
to do a full turn around to the right
and then come back out. Same thing when
I'm going back to the left. Now, what
you can do here is you can just hang out
and do as many reps of Xan's diamond as
you like. But when you decide to make
your turn, you're imagining that you've
just gone all the way back around and
then coming back out at the point that
you would have arrived at originally. So
if I'm coming from the right and I do
that pureette, I come to the left and
open up like so. Same thing when I'm
going over to the right, to the left, to
the right,
to the left. Tada.
So, those are three different options
for how you can flow with Xan's Diamond,
how you can dance with it and take what
should be a tech trick and make it just
a little bit prettier. Uh, were there
other options for dancing with Xan's
Diamond that I didn't include in this
video? Please leave me a comment and let
me know what your favorites might have
been. Also, be sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to uh make sure
that other people can find this video
and to help my channel grow.
Hey friends. So, I just want to put out
a huge thank you to the lovely and
talented Jennifer Ever Swanson for
running the camera for this video. Uh,
thank you so much. The camera work was
beautiful and I cannot wait to do this
again with you. Thank you.
>> Thank you. This video and all the videos
on this channel would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I'd love to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you
all so much for your very generous
support. And if you out there watching
would like to get your name in the
credits or access to a host of other
awesome rewards, pretty please go and
check out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and sign up. I will include a link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. So, please go check that out and
help me out in my mission of bringing po
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. Thank you in advance. And if all
these dance terms sound like Greek to
you, I have good news. I did a short
series of videos last year on different
basic dance moves and how they can
interact with poi. I'll go ahead and
include a link to that playlist up here
on screen as well as down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care. Peace.